a little bit well you know what's really
fascinating and what Netflix is proven
to viewing habits and such is that you
don't have to be a white person to watch
a white show you don't have to be an
Asian person to watch an Asian show like
if you look at crazy rich Asians
I don't think white people are bi people
are like I'm not gonna see that because
it's all Asian you watch Korean dramas
love hello my twenties roommates the
girls and then one of them is kind of
like being out yes yes I watch a first
couple music gets even nuttier is it
good
you watched fury I'm sorry Curie's
bed-and-breakfast no but I will let me
write that dates it's a reality show
it's basically she's something like the
Britney Spears of Korea oh and then she
and her husband moved to Jeju Island
where they have a house and they open up
their doors for a bed-and-breakfast and
they have like 16 dogs you told me about
this but see this proves my point like
the way that television was created is
that well we got to make shows geared
towards certain demographics the male 13
to whatever 20 year old is going to only
watch Tom Green on him to me it's not
true yes you've got people watching all
kinds of [ __ ] if it's good yeah yeah
another great one a good cop Korean cop
dramas called live it's on Netflix to
another sliver like see why do we know
all this stuff cuz it's good yeah it's
just good i watch i watch anything in
any language yeah yeah but still I mean
but I had that defend the Midwest here
for a second oh wow in a negative way is
that still dumb Americans right will not
will not watch anything that has
subtitles in it yeah I got a honest
sometimes I'm too tired to read yeah
yeah I can't wait TV right now that's
how they we remake things like if it's a
like they remade what's that vampire one
that I like Let The Right One In yeah oh
they really what did you see which one
did you see the American version or the
Swedish one it's all old ass
did you see this with a European version
yeah I do like a million years yeah yeah
they beat up a white one they
American women their worldwide oh cool
they remade La Femme Nikita which was
[ __ ] laughs the original one right
with Lukas ah yes yes they remade it
into you know me and an American created
the did the departed oh yeah is an Asian
movie infernal affair yeah so they
stayed do that a lot so I and and and
and it works I mean people go oh boy
yeah I've seen good but the remake I I
heard wasn't very good right yeah what's
his name uh Josh brought battle royale
oh no never
people go it's like anyone listening
right now all right I know you guys
sometimes hear you hear me and you like
the ruling brothers you guys downloaded
that album we have these friends from
you from England that would did Tiger
belly they're a band called ruin
brothers two brothers they sound like
Roy Orbison they're so good easing but
if you want to listen to me right now
one of the best movies I've ever it's a
great movie it's called battle royale
the original one there's number they did
three movies I think but watch the first
one it's so good so good and it was not
it was like unlike anything else that
came out at the time because I remember
seeing I think was in the late 90s right
yeah it was crazy bloody yeah and it was
in what just the premise of it is I
guess it it's post
it's like future gee up Japan not that
far like not Blade Runner future but in
the and and and and the Japanese youth
is out of control
yeah so they do a lottery system where
is if you're in the bottom of the of the
classes that are misbehaving you get
thrown in this lottery system where if
you if you win it you have to do a
reality show called battle royale is
basically your class goes on an island
and they film it as a show and you and
you have to kill each other
until one person stand a row he's [ __ ]
rad do you think a young Bobby Lee would
have done oh well you would have been
you would have been I wouldn't want I
wouldn one of the guy because people
died even before they got on the island
because I'm gonna be the one that's we
like no [ __ ] this did you mean that you
know I don't I think that if we were on
an island right
it was the same rules yeah let's be
honest with ourselves right now who do
you think so us six who would who would
be the first to die think you were
really sick hide go to tolls like an
arrow wouldn't penetrate you what cuz
I'm fat no you haven't
I know why like six clerics again yeah
yeah yeah I'm tighter like if you
scratch him you will feel anything if I
get away this heals back up like
Wolverine yeah now are you prone to
eczema no no he has perfect baby skin on
his back that's my skin maybe we'll do
this first do you think the men can
overpower us I don't know how strong you
are yeah I have really good stamina hmm
I think it's enough and I have like I
feel like are we trying to kill each
other oh yeah everyone everyone has what
kind of weapons do we have do without
their rifles will just do hand-to-hand
combats in this room whatever you can
find in this room you get one thing in
this room right you get a pet pencil
what the [ __ ] dude dude oh yeah I can
make this into a shard of glass a knife
you see my size door yeah take one no
he's a karate one of the sticks the
tripods I think I'll be the first to die
if I'm thinking about it I think I would
be but I feel like you would I think you
just hire out no no you would try to
create alliances like
survivor you'd like pull people aside
are you trying to get us to fight each
other I'll give you more more money for
Tiger barley
give it more percentage we go do you go
to breathe rice the doors all separately
to say that yeah you get more merchant
money you might be the last to live
because you're gonna use your smarts
honey
okay if you guys ever seen like a royal
rumble in WWE you gotta stay on outer
fringes first you can't engage first
because then you're just out no matter
how strong you are I'm running the
opposite direction and when you're the
last one living and you're looking after
me I will have been well rested
somewhere in a cave and then you'll be
tired from fighting [ __ ] five people
and then I will shank you right in your
[ __ ] eyeballs
you know why Firoz I'll be on an island
and I'm [ __ ] walking around I see a
cave and I walk in the cave and Bryce
and kalila in there he has repent over
all wrong you told me in the middle
I'm starting to realize something about
you I think you're a true cook I think
he always brings up these situations
where he finds me having sex with
whoever the hell is enterprise it's
always Bryce no it's always what you
you've mentioned sex with him I wouldn't
be like Keeling over laughing but but
also part of that your [ __ ] fantasy is
the fact that you do like Bryce a lot oh
it is wait a minute does he have like
what did that guy like yeah I have to
have something to feel sort of attracted
to them interesting how do they have an
encounter to or he just watch you feel
cornered
yeah listen Bryce Bryce he does like
Bryce in terms of the Tiger belly family
so the tiger felt Billy family is what
eight people is it how many people is it
for no we have cameramen too
[Music]